Humans created farming around 12,000 years
ago.
But there was another species that independently
created farming waaay before we did….
55 million years before, in fact.
It wasn’t the neanderthal, or any ape, actually…
it was an insect.
The lowly ant.
Specifically these guys.
You’ve all probably seen a clip like this
on a nature documentary, setting the scene
of a wild rainforest.
But, in the rainforest it’s not really obvious
what they’re doing.
Let me put it this way, if you put leafcutter
ants into an ant farm, and watched them build
a colony.
You’d have an ant farm farm!
They don’t farm corn or cows -- but fungus!
(we’ll come back to that).
Leafcutter ants like the famous Atta cephalotes
literally cut leaves and then carry them on
their backs to their colony.
But have you ever thought what they do when
they get there?
Because the ants don’t eat those leaves
they carry.
That’s what I thought they did.
Nope.
They use them to grow crops… for agriculture!
Agriculture, by definition is “the science
or practice of farming, including cultivation
of the soil for the growing of crops and the
rearing of animals to provide food, wool,
and other products.”
Ants are doing this!
They dig growing chambers in deep tunnels
to control the temperature, and bring dew
and water from the surface to the chambers
to control humidity of their crops
-- and this is where the leaves come in.
The Atta ants drink the sap, clean the leaves,
crush them up, and compost them with their
own fecal liquid.
And the fungus (basidiomycete type) grows
on this “soil” they create.
Then, they harvest bits of the fungus and
use it to feed the colony.
Just like human farmers.
We’re still new to farming.
Wheat is one of the oldest farmed grains,
but it wasn’t until Norman Borlaug bred
two special wheats together that humans could
finally use it to feed millions of people!
He won the Nobel Peace Prize for that in 1970.
But that is n00b science in comparison to
ants who have been using agriculture to feed
millions of ants for millions of years.
Atta ants have evolved over millions of years
alongside their crops, weeding, watering,
and preening.
One species of ant has even cultivated a fungal
line that produces high-yields to feed more
ants!
No Peace prize for them though.
The coolest part about this, is some of the
250 species of ant that have evolved agriculture,
have also cultivated their crop so much, that
without the ants, it would die.
The fungus only exists to feed the ants!
The other cool thing?
Ants aren’t the only farming species out
there.
Termites also are fungal farmers -- and here
you thought they were just eating your house,
nope they feed some bits to their fungal friends.
Damselfish are the only known fish to be agriculturalists,
farming algae for their food.
There are even species of beetle and snail
with this practice.
But c’mon.
Why should we care?
Because we’ve only been farming 12,000 years.
And scientists are not sure farming is sustainable
practice.
We have to feed billions of people, meaning
we need monocultures -- one super-plant that
can feed lots of people, like the Borlaug
wheat.
But growing crops this way can deplete soil
(like with corn) or subject large crops to
disease (like with monoculture bananas).
The Atta ants and other fungal farmers have
been cultivating monocultures for millions
of years.
If we can learn how they manage to avoid devastation
by disease, or how they protect their crops
from parasites -- maybe we could support another
few billion of our own human colony.
Aren't ants awesome?
Want to learn more about them?
We talked to a bug scientist and you can check
out the interview here.
What do y’all think of these mini farmers?
Let us know in the comments, and don’t forget
to subscribe, and come back for more videos.